exercé en Corse après les assassinats de
ressortissants nord-africains le
secrétaire d'État chargé des immigrés
s'est rendu dans l'île pour examiner les
problèmes que pose la présence
importante d'une population étrangère un
reportage de FR3
àjaction maintenant j'ai cru comprendre
à travers les observations qui ont été
faites aujourd'hui qu'il y avait un
problème de logement assez
important que nous étions en train de
régler et et qui nécessitait bien sûr
des mesures urgentes et que nous ne
manquerions pas de prendre est-ce que
vous pensez que la population immigrée
encore s'est rejeté encore plus
particulièrement que dans les autres
départements j'ai pas l'impression je
crois au contraire que si on met entre
parenthès ce qui vient de se passer que
au
contraire la cohavitation se faisait
dans des conditions très harmonieus et
que j'étis très surpris par les
événements dramatiques de ces derniers
jours que je condamne bien sûr parce
qu'il s'agit là manifestement d'après
les premiers éléments deenquête d'un
attentat raciste je le condamne comme le
condamne certainement tous les habitants
de la Corse qui sont connus pour leur
tradition de générosité d'accueil est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas qu'une des
premières mesures à prendre c'est de
limiter les entré sur le département de
cors ah mais cette non seulement cette
mesure
est prendre mais elle a déjà été prise
vous savez que le premier ministre dans
sa
déclaration de politique général au mois
de juillet 81 a indiqué que la France ne
pouvait plus accueillir de nouveaux
travailleurs étrangers que par
conséquent les frontières étaient
fermées et que de ce point de vue-l la
Corse est un département français par
conséquent il y a aucun problème de
ceou maintenant j'ai cru comprendre à
travers les observations qui ont été
faites aujourd'hui qu'il y avait un
problème de logement assez
important que nous étions en train de
régler et qui nécessitait bien sûr des
mesures urgentes et que nous ne
manquerions pas de prendre est-ce que
vous penser que la population immigrée
encore s'est rejeté encore plus
particulièrement que dans les autres
départements j'ai pas l'impression je
crois au contraire que si on on met
entre parenthèses ce qui vient de se
passer que au
contraire la cohitation se faisait dans
des conditions très harmonieuses et que
j'étais très surpris par les événements
dramatiques de ces derniers jours que je
condamne bien sûr parce qu'il s'agit là
manifestement d'après les premiers
éléments d'enquête d'un attentat raciste
je le condamne comme le condamne
certainement tous les habitants de la
Corse qui sont connus pour leur
tradition de générosité d'accueil est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas qu'une des
premières mesures à prendre c'est de
limiter les entrées sur le département
Corse ah mais cette non seulement cette
mesure est est à prendre mais elle a
déjà été prise vous savez que le premier
ministre dans sa
déclaration de politique générale au
mois de juillet 81 a indiqué que la
France ne pouvait plus accueillir de
nouveaux travailleurs étrangers par
conséquent les frontières c'est fermé et
que de ce point de vue là la Corse est
un département français par conséquent
il y a aucun problème de ce point V
là calvie c'est une ville touristique en
été mais toute l'année c'est une ville
de garnison les militaires ce sont les
légionnaires du 2è REP cantonné au C
rafali au maximum 1200 hommes l'on dit
souvent des chosose sur la légion mais
ce n'était jusqu'à présent que des
rumeurs depuis hier ce ne sont plus des
rumeurs mais des déclarations trois
légionnaires parlent pour la première
fois Jean-Jacques mages 26 ans
caporal c'est assez difficile à
expliquer
mais je je reviendrai à cette chose
choquante j''y avais pensé moi en voyant
le les mois s'écouler les derniers moi
qui me reste à faire au sein de la lgion
étrangère s'écoulé je me suis dit ce
n'est pas possible que toi un
réfractaire qui ne partage pas les idées
du commandement dans la Légion étrangère
puisse finir ta finir ta carrière
paisiblement dans ton petit coin sans
rien dire en voyant ce que ce que tu
vois
quotidiennement
et le déclic a été l'affaire du du du
caporal ubert qui s'est fait tablacer
suite à une dénonciation à cause d'une
lettre qu' qu'il avait l'intention
d'envoyer à son
frère Patrick Hubert 26 ans caporal il a
écrit à ses parents pour dire qu'il
n'était pas bien à la Légion on a trouvé
sa
lettre j'étais lé contre le bureau Gau
ça je peux leter de toute façon c'est
important au Gard vous et après ensuite
bon à TR dans le bureau il y en a qui
m'a conné dessus mais enfin TR pour rien
faire un qui m'a conné dessus sans
autrre explication à partir de cette
lettrre à partir de cette
lettrre Paul Duroc 21 ans
caporal j'ai fait c'est une demande de
résation de contrat qui est monté au
nouveau chef de section ça n'est jamais
monté plus haut pas parce que je n'ai
pas insisté puis que j'ai tout fait
enfin je pense avoir fait le maximum qui
était Mo maximum de M possibilités par
la voie hiérarchique par la voie
mais j'étais complètement bloqué au
niveau d'un chef de section qui na rien
voulu savoir B c'estcendu au niveau des
caporo j'étais catalogué comme un
élément douteux alors que je suis parti
d'AGNE avec d'excellentes
notes susceptible de faire un futur
futur responsable au sein laégion
étrangère bon il s'avère que ça m'a pas
plu je m'en suis rendu compte au bout de
4 jours qu'est-ce que vous appelez sice
physique
ben j'ai j'ai vu plusieurs de mes
camarades d'instruction ramasser des
baffes des coups de point ou des
simplement en toute simplicité des
passages à tabac pour par exemple une
armoir rangé ce qui m'est arrivé
effectivement en
1978 au mois de juillet quand j'étais à
Cal qu'est-ce que vous voudriez pour que
ça change comme vous
dites personnellement moi je voudrais
obtenir une entrevue avec une très haute
personnalité de
l'État parce que la hiérarchie
ça ne sert qu'à mettre des bâtons dans
les roues j'ai écrit une lettre à
l'étatmajor particulier de l'Élysée la
lettre est bien arrivée j'ai téléphoné
j'ai eu confirmation de l'arrivée de la
lettre mais ceux qui ont reçu la lettre
m'ont dit qu'il ne pouvait absolument
rien faire pour des questions d'ordre
hiérarchique qu'il fallait passer par la
hiérarchie militaire évidemment pour des
raisons évidentes je ne peux pas passer
par la hiérarchie militaire alors la
lettre est resté
morte
le centre hospitalier d'ajaaco a
longtemps assuré des prestation
insuffisante et incomplète ces finalités
en 1982 ne peuvent plus être celles de
19 9 date de sa création les
responsables du centre l'ont très bien
compris il n'ont pas voulu rester isolés
et ont recherché le développement de
secteurs originaux c'est ainsi qui a été
mise en place en 1975 le service
desmoialyes une réalisation sanitaire
qui s'est faite contre vant et Maré ils
étaient nombreux en effet à s'opposer à
son ouverture et à son fonctionnement
une attitude dépassée aujourd'hui
lorsque l'on sait que les insuffisants
Réau chroniques traduisaient les malades
qui ne peuvent vivre sans le rein
artificiel duquel ils sont dépend
sont au nombre de 8000 en France pour
42000 en Europe premièrement ça évite au
malad résident en Corse de devoir se
rendre trois fois par semaine sur le
continent pour subir leur traitement et
deuxièmement ça permet d'accueillir dans
l'île les Corses du continent qui
rentrent pendant leur vacances et deuxè
et ensuite d'accueillir un certain
nombre de vacanciers du continent ou
même étrangers qui souhaitent venir
encore se passer 15 jours ou un mois en
chiffre combien de patients sont-ils
concernés par
service bien actuellement on peut dire
que nous traitons 25 résidents Corse et
pendant la période estivale environ 48
résidents plus vacanciers qui restent en
moyenne 15 jours 3 semaines ce service
est-il suffisamment bien étaufé en
matériel et en personnel pour répondre à
la demande pour ce qui est des
vacanciers euh nous sommes toujours
pleins le mois de juillet et août et
peut-être qu'une extension serait
souhaitable mais ça nécessiterait un
surcroix de personnel un surcroix de
matériel enfin d'autres conditions qui
sont pas réalisées
actuellement c'est le 14
parle monsieur le ministre il y a
environ de cela 6 mois sur le BEM avec
Monsieur le pinse et Paul Guimard vous
avez énoncé les grandes lignes de la
politique que vous comptiez suivre dans
le domaine culturel et s'agissant de la
mer alors depuis ces 6 mois est-ce que
les choses ont progressé notamment je
pense à tout ce qui approche la
Méditerranée
pas seulement la Méditerranée mais comme
nous avons la chance habitant le
territoire français d'être baigné par
deux grandes mè la Méditerranée est
l'une de ces deux grandes mers et en
effet récemment nous avons réuni non pas
en France mais sur une petite île
grecque àidra l'initiative du
gouvernement grec et du gouvernement
français des créateurs des artistes de
20 pays de la
Méditerranée
invitant tous ces créateurs à réfléchir
sur ce que pourrait être dans un avenir
plus ou moins proche la création d'une
véritable communauté culturelle de la
Méditerranée la M commune comme on
dit a été Dison foyer de civilisation et
cultture et la question qui était posée
éit de savoir si dans cette période de
nivellement et de rabottage des cultures
une alliance entre les créateurs et
artistes de la mer Méditerranée
pouvaient constituer un contre poid ce
nivellement et puis il y avait aussi une
préoccupation politique
essayer de d'établir des
lien entre des hommes de culture qui
sont habituellement séparés par les
frontières ou par les conflits et je
pense en particulier à la présence
àidra d'intellectuels israéliens
d'intellectuels palestiniens qui ont pu
côte à côte ensemble travailler pendant
3 jours et proposer une solution commune
une solution de reconnaissance Mutu
du droit des Palestiniens et du droit
des Israéliens voilà si vous voulez une
série de de de de questions posé à hdra
mais cette réunion n'était pas s
lendemain dans quelques jours dans le
langdoc Rousillon et en Provence Côte
d'Azur de nouvelles réunions vont avoir
lieu dans un cadre beaucoup plus large
sur les rapports culturels Nord-Sud sur
la base du discours prononcé à Mexico
par François miteran établir des
rapports plus justes entre les pays du
Nord et les pays du Sud pas seulement
sur le plan économique mais sur le plan
culturel aussi et Jérôme Savari et le TH
de la Méditerranée réunissent pendant
plusieurs jours des écrivains des
cinéastes des chanteurs de différents
pays et cela se terminera je crois le 14
juin par un très grand spectacle dans
les arènes
d'Arles conçu par Béjard et associant
des artistes des danseurs et des
musiciens de tous les pays de la
Méditerranée
alors on a pas choisi nî bien que Madame
jordine A du foie
mais ne soit pas
là